Hi, I'm Sarah from Instructables...
...and today I'm going to show you how to make an awesome chocolate cake.
In one mug, with one microwave, in under five minutes.
So, we've got some very basic ingredients here.
We need four tablespoons of flour, four tablespoons of sugar,...
... one heaping tablespoon of cocoa, three tablespoons of milk, three tablespoons of oil,...
...two tablespoons of whisked egg and a splash of vanilla.
And now we're gonna mix it all up.
Doesn't that look good?
Finally, we're going to add chocolate chips.
About three tablespoons, but pretty much as much as you like is fine.
Because chocolate chips is what's gonna take this cake from good to amazing.
It's ready for the microwave.
While it's cooking, you might notice it rise over the top of the mug.
And that's fine, that's what you want.
If it spills over the top of the mug,...
...it's still okay, it still tastes good.
But next time get a bigger mug.
There it goes.
Rising, rising, looking good.
Oh my gosh!
It's perfect.
For more information about the five-minute chocolate cake...
...or thousands of other cool projects,...
...follow the link at the bottom of the screen back to instructables.com...
...where you can get step-by-step detailed instructions.
Okay, I'm gonna eat it.
Very good!